this video is sponsored by great two
courses plus but more on that later in
the video
[Music]
at all events the Praetorian troops that
were sent by the Emperor Nero under the
command of a Tribune for the purposes of
inquiry when among the other Wars he was
contemplating an expedition against
Ethiopia brought back word that they had
met with nothing but deserts on their
route the Roman arms also had penetrated
into these regions in the time of the
late Emperor Augustus under the command
of people Onias a man of equestrian rank
and prefect of Egypt that general took
the following cities the only ones we
find mentioned there in the following
order
Celsus Primus a bunkies therus Cambyses
at over and stood ASUS where the river
nile as it thunders down the precipices
as quite deprived the inhabitants of the
power of hearing the extreme distance to
which he penetrated beyond Celine was
970 miles but still it was not the Roman
arms that rented these regions a desert
Ethiopia in its turn gaining the mastery
and then again reduced to servitude was
at last worn out by its continual wars
with Egypt having been a famous and
powerful country even at the time of the
Trojan War when memnon was its king it
is also very evident from the fabulous
stories about Andromeda that you ruled
over Syria in the time of King Cepheus
and that its sway extended as far as the
shores of our sea this video sponsored
by great causes plus a fantastic
educational resource that myself and my
brother Pete at history time have been
using for a while now
here at voices of the past we provide
you with the raw historical text but if
you want to add context and layers of
meaning to the videos great causes plus
as it has been for us can be a great
resource for you it's a subscription
on-demand video learning service with
the University quality learning at a
fraction of the price our University
course with mountains of topics to
choose from
the good news for us Brits is that the
great courses plus is now optimized for
streaming in the UK and Australia as
well personally I've been particularly
enjoying recently this course by Craig G
Benjamin giving me an insight into the
foundation of Eastern history great
context and inspiration for future
videos so to sign up please head over to
the great courses plus.com forward slash
voices to start your free trial now
there has also been conflicting accounts
as to the extent of this country first
by Dalian who travelled a considerable
distance beyond where our way and after
him by aristocracy and basileus as well
as by the youngest simona d's who made a
stay of five years at Murrow way when he
wrote his account of Ethiopia
demosthenes however the commander of the
fleet's of Philadelphus without giving
any other estimate as to the distance
says that Murrow way is sixty days
journey from Syene while Eratosthenes
states that the distance is 625 miles
and our Tim odorous 600 all these
differences however have since been
settled for the persons sent by Nero for
the purposes of discovery have reported
that the distance from saying tomorrow a
is 871 miles the following being the
items
from Syene to hierra sick aminos they
make to be 54 miles from thence to Tama
72 to the country of the Ivana me to AV
first region of Ethiopia 122 Akina 54 to
Bottari 25 and to turgid us 106 they
stayed also that the island of giggle
des lies it in equal distance from Syene
and Moreau way and that it is at this
place that the bird called the parrot
was first seen while at another island
called articular the animal known as
this finger must discovered by them and
after passing Turgut us that connect a
phallus the distance from thence turn a
beta is 80 miles that little town being
the only one of all of them that now
survives from thence to the island of
meroe the distance is 360 miles they
also state that the grass in the
vicinity of Moreau a becomes a greener
and fresher cover and that there is some
slight appearance of forests has also
traces of the rhinoceros and elephant
they reported also that the city of
meroe stands at a distance of 70 miles
from the first entrance of the island of
Moreau way and that close to it is
another Island Tardieu by name which
forms a harbour facing those who enter
the right hand channel of the river the
buildings in the city they said were but
few a number and they stated that a
female whose name was Candace ruled over
the district that name having passed
from Queen - Queen for many years
they related also that there was a
temple of Jupiter ham on there held in
great of veneration
besides smaller shrines erected in honor
of him throughout all the country in
addition to these particulars they were
informed that in the days of the
Ethiopian domination the island of meroe
enjoyed great renown that according to
tradition it was in the habit of
maintaining two hundred thousand armed
men and four thousand artisans the kings
of Ethiopia are said even at the present
day to be forty-five in number
[Music]
the whole of this country has
successively had the names of atheria
Atlantia and last of all Ethiopia from
ethiop's the son of Vulcan it is not at
all surprising that towards the
extremity of this region the men and
animals assume a monstrous form when we
consider the changeable nurse and
volubility of fire the heat of which is
the great agent in imparting various
forms and shapes in bodies indeed it is
reported that in the interior on the
eastern side there is a people who have
no noses the whole face presenting a
plain surface that others again are
destitute of an upper lip and others are
without tongues others again have the
mouth were owned together and being
destitute of nostrils breathe through
one passage only imbibing their drink
through it by means of the hollow stalk
of the oat which there grows
spontaneously and supplies them with its
grain for food some of these nations
have to employ gestures by nodding the
head and moving the limbs instead of
speech others again were unacquainted
with the use of fire before the time of
Ptolemy Lazarus king of Egypt some
writers also stated that there is a
nation of pygmies which dwells among the
marshes in which the River Nile takes
its rise while on the coast of Ethiopia
where we paused there is a range of
mountains of a red color which have the
appearance of being always burning
all the country after we passed Morelle
way is bounded by the troglodyte a and
the Red Sea it being three days journey
from Napa to the shores of that see
throughout the whole of this district
the rainwater is carefully preserved at
several places while the country that
lies between is extremely productive of
gold the parts beyond this are inhabited
by the atom Bewley a nation of ethiopia
and here over against Moroni are the
mega berry by some writers called the
ADEA berry they occupy the city of
Apollo
some of them however are nomads living
on the flesh of elephants opposite to
them on the African side dwelled the
Macra be and then again beyond the mega
bari there are the mem Nene's and the
dabeli and at a distance of twenty days
journey the Croton see beyond these are
the don't she and then the Jim Nettie's
who always go naked and after them the
and debt a the Moffatt a and the episode
or a who are of a black tint but stained
the body all over with a kind of red
earth on the African side again there
are the madam knee and then a nation of
nomads who live on the milk of the
connect of phallus and then the alladhi
and the Servet a which last a said to be
eight cubits in height Paris token
informs us that on the Libyan side at a
distance of five days journey from Meroe
is the town of torez and then it a
further distance of 12 days journey SR a
town founded by the Egyptians who fled
from sama tshis he states also that they
dwelt there for a period of three
hundred years and that opposite on the
Arabian side there is a town of theirs
called a Darin the town however which he
calls SR is by by on called sap a who
says that their name means the strangers
their capital being Sam Baba TISS
situated on an island and the third
place of theirs
Sinnott in Arabia between the mountains
and the River Nile are the sim Bari the
colleges and on the mountains themselves
the Asaka who are divided into numerous
peoples they are said to be distance
five days
from the sea and procure their
subsistence by the chase of the elephant
an island in the Nile which belongs to
the semper arte is governed by a queen
beyond it are the Ethiopian knew by at a
distance of eight days journey a town is
tuned abscess situated on the Nile there
are the sasamori also are people among
whom all the quadrupeds are without ears
the very elephants even on the African
side are the Tana Bari the tonfa are
people who have a dog for their king and
divide from his movements what are his
commands the eros be who have a town at
a considerable distance from the Nile
and then the arch Asami beyond is the
region of Surbiton at which the
mountains terminate and which by some
writers is said to contain the maritime
Ethiopians than this eka thay and the
necessity a word which signifies men
with three or four eyes not the people
who really have that confirmation but
because they are remarkable for the
unerring aim of their arrows on that
side of the Nile which extends along the
borders of the southern ocean beyond the
greater Surtees de Leon says that the
people who use rainwater only are called
the Sasori and that the other nations of
the long-gone pori distance five days
journey from Loserville kathy is barely
the Peruzzi the barley and the sis pea
the rest bean deserts and inhabited by
the tribes of Fable only in a more
westerly direction than Nigro i whose
king has only one eye and that in the
forehead the angry frg who live
principally on the flesh of panthers and
lions the pam fargy who will eat
anything the anthropophagi who live on
human flesh the cinema gear people with
the heads of dogs and art of a DJ who
have four feet and wander about after
the manner of wild beasts and after them
the Hesper a and the Perrault see whom
we have already spoken of as dwelling on
the confines of Mauritania some tribes
two of the Ethiopians subsist on nothing
but locusts
which are smoked dried and salted as
their provision for the year these
people do not live long beyond their
40th year Agrippa was of the opinion
that the length of the whole country of
the Ethiopians including the Red Sea was
two thousand one hundred and seventy
miles at its breadth including Upper
Egypt twelve hundred and ninety seven
some authors again have made the
following divisions of its length from
Moreau a to a certain eleven days sail
from serve atom to the dabeli fifteen
days and from them to the Ethiopian
Ocean just six days journey it is agreed
by most authors that the distance
altogether from the ocean to Moroni is
625 miles and from Moroni to Syene that
which we have already mentioned Ethiopia
lies from South East to South West
situated as it is in a southern
hemisphere forests of Ebony are to be
seen of the brightest Verdier and in the
midst of these regions there is a
mountain of immense height which
overhangs the sea and emits a perpetual
flame by the Greeks this mountain is
called Theron okema and at a distance of
four days sail from it is a promontory
known as Hesperus eros upon the confines
of africa the sources of the Nile are
unattained and travelling as it does for
an immense distance through deserts and
burning sands it is only known to us by
common report having neither experience
the vicissitudes of warfare nor been
visited by those arms which have so
effectually explored all other regions
it rises so far indeed as King Juba was
enabled to ascertain in a mountain of
lower Mauritania not far from the ocean
immediately after which it forms a lake
of standing water
which bears the name of Neleus giving
birth in its course to dense forests of
trees it travels through the middle of
Ethiopia under the name of hasta puss a
word which signifies in the language of
the nations who dwell in these regions
water issuing from the shades below
proceeding onwards it divides
innumerable islands in its course and
some of them of such vast magnitude that
although its tides run with the greatest
rapidity is not less than five days in
passing them it does not obtain the name
Nile until its waters have again met and
are united in a single stream and even
then for some miles both above and below
the point of confluence it has the name
of serious